all right time now for what's trending
tonight
[Music]
it's our first look at the long-awaited
whitney houston biopic i want to dance
with somebody a common criticism of you
your music isn't black enough
look i don't know how to sing black and
i don't know how to sing white either
i know how to sing
the late singer is portrayed by naomi
aki but the musical numbers will use
whitney's own recordings because no one
can recreate the voice
now to blake lively and ryan reynolds
who were expecting baby number four
blake debuted her new bump at forbes
power women's summit new york beaming in
a sequence mini dress e.t canada has
reached out to the couple for comment
next up real housewives of beverly hills
star erica jane claps back at jennifer
lawrence the oscar winner made headlines
this week when she sat down with variety
at tiff and gave her thoughts on erica's
performance this season i think that
erica is
evil
[Laughter]
i would go as far as to say um she needs
a publicist
eric er strange husband tom girardi have
faced numerous lawsuits alleging they
funded their lavish lifestyle with
settlement money from widows and orphans
but her ambivalence towards the scandal
has irked viewers and even her own
girlfriends i don't give a about anybody
else but me you're not showing any
any compassion on wednesday's watch what
happens live erica addressed jayla's
comments but anytime that she would like
to come on down and mix it up with us
i'm sure that we could unmask the ugly
parts of her personality as well
and on the late late show kim kardashian
tells james corden she's in no rush to
date again following her split from pete
davidson i'm not looking i just want to
chill for a minute but when she does get
back out there she says she might start
looking in new places clearly it's not
working whatever i'm doing right so i
feel i don't know maybe like a hospital
and meet a doctor
right so if we ever see like paparazzi
shots of like kim kardashian spotted at
nasa we'll be like
[Music]